[Musik]
die ganz klar beste nebendarstellerin
ist glaube ich allerdings weil die hat
es fast geschafft dass ich mir das sogar
angeguckt hätte dieses war ist und das
finde ich also jemanden beeindruckend
der in den film dann gar nicht reingeht
ich weiß gar nicht wie ich das
beschreiben soll dem king ist sehr gut
in dem dfb trikot
neben euren scheiß mit am schlimmsten
wäre emma stone oder rachel weisz weil
die super gut waren und zwar gleich
super gut waren in einem wahnsinnig
guten film und dann ist eine sauer und
die wirken auch so aggressiv dass die
eine wahrscheinliche anderen die ecke
bringt und dann haben wir eine super
schauspielerin weniger ich könnte mir
vorstellen dass das gelegenheit wäre
mannes zu machen und die amazonen die
hübsche weiß zusammen auszuzeichnen weil
sie wirklich ein solches ping pong
spieler in diesem film und sich wirklich
ebenbürtig sind wenn denn eine der
beiden hier nominierten
nebendarstellerinnen und da ist mir
eigentlich egal wer es ist den oscar für
die beste nebenrolle in empfang nimmt
dann wäre ich ziemlich glücklich und
wenn vielleicht noch ein paar technische
oscars die kostüme und so was dazukommen
naja gut der sollte schon finde ich mit
sophia oder fünf oscars aus der gesamten
nacht herausgehen und bitte dann
wenigstens den für die beste
nebendarstellerin
volksstimme ich glaube mein favorit wird
sich mit dem preisträger decken nämlich
mm treiber der ist grandios in seiner
richtig komischen rolle in black
klinsmann ich riskiere nicht mein leben
weil ein paar rednecks zusammengebundene
stückchen abfackeln war das ist unsere
aufgabe
was ist dein problem ist mein problem
ist für dich ist es ein kreuzzug für
mich ist es ein job es ist ml den star
is born und zwar die überlegung dahinter
ist dass star is born dann noch mehr
ausgelegt und das ist wenn ihr das
strategie ich wenn du ein oscar kriegst
du was gar keinen sinn hat das taktik
aber wenn du was ausgefressen hat ist
schattigen beherrschen die ja wohl nicht
seine beste rolle spielt in einem
fürchterlichen film aber er ist halt
einfach ein teil
man sieht wie mit gewalt tony gewinnen
kann man nur wenn man seine würde
bewahrt denn würde würde obsiegt hört
mich deshalb so irre freuen weil dann
der falschen kategorie nominiert ist er
müsste als bester hauptdarsteller
nominiert sein und da hat er diesen
preis auch finde ich allemal verdient
und würde wahrscheinlich
gewinnen als nebendarsteller bin ich
skeptisch aus fairnessgründen sollte ihn
kriegen aber die bessere leistung hat
einen driver gezeigt und ich glaube das
merken sogar die leute von der academy
setzt ich weiß dass dein juden labor
stellst du dir deine seife her und deine
lampenschirm du machst nur einen
lügendetektortest von denen die
nominiert sind wo ich die filme gesehen
habe würde ich sagen kommt nur bradley
cooper in frage wenn ich meine wünsche
verwirklicht sehen denn der hat mir viel
freude gemacht der spielt das richtig
toll im star is born
[Musik]
er ist so charmant und er hat soviel
kapiert in diesem in dieser performance
von dem was zwischen zwei leuten
vorgehen kann
in guten wie in schlechten zeiten das
nicht total ungarn ja das machen
[Musik]
der ganz klar bester hauptdarsteller ist
will und dafür aus dem einfachen grund
weil ich überhaupt noch nie in meinem
ganzen leben so schlechten film gesehen
habe wie diesen der turner die skate von
julian schnabel über vincent van gogh
also den anfang hat sich wahrscheinlich
wegen diesem film umgebracht und das
tolle ist halt mal richtig ganze zeit
rauslaufen das faszinierende ist dass
man eben sieht wir sind da wo darf ja
auch nicht rauslaufen das heißt er muss
dauernd mitmachen allerdings war erhält
das dennoch nicht mehr aus und rennt weg
und er tut es nicht und so und dieses
diese verbindung die dadurch entsteht
dass das hat mich einfach sehr berührt
dass der das aushält und wahrscheinlich
haben wir viel geld und das heißt ich
kann da ich gar nicht richtig zu
versprechen und ich finde da muss diesen
preis bekommen halten sind finde ich
muss das nicht kriegen nur weil er sich
den dicken bauch angefressen hat und so
spricht wirkt auch nicht so ganz schön
armselig toni
also ich muss zugeben dass ich es ein
bisschen leid bin dass leute für extreme
körperliche erfahrungen beim rollen
einstudieren für oscars nominiert werden
und das gilt hier direkt für zwei mit
viggo mortensen für christian bale am
allerschlimmsten wäre wahrscheinlich und
kristen bell hinbekommen würde weil das
dann ermutigt würde dass man sich voll
frist für eine rolle oder wir ja schon
mal gemacht hat sich wie bis zum stock
ab magath keine rolle weil diese
verwechslung von unterhaltung sport
eurovision contest und anderen
disziplinen bei denen sich menschen in
irgend einer form zu sein machen mit dem
was was kino ist wie kino ist einfach du
kommst dahin ist irgendwie cool wie
klaus kinski und ein totales arschloch
und das allerletzte denken die verse
habe und stellt das halt da und dann ist
der film fertig und stattdessen
irgendwas machen zu müssen wie bei
seinem training oder so das gehört
wirklich sehr sehr schwer misshandelt
und bestraft erfahrungsgemäß gewinnt
einer von den beiden garantiert und
natürlich wird es christian bale sein
der hat zwar glaube ich auch schon den
oscar aber da liebt hollywood mehr vor
auszeichnungen darum glaube ich der wird
gewinnen
kachelmann wird sich heute der presse
kaum erwehren können daher rate ich
ihnen seine anrufe zu kontrollieren ich
glaub glenn close wäre das schlimmste
weil ich habe angst vor dir also ich
glaube einfach dass die dann so davon
irgendwie messer kauft oder irgendwas
und dann wache ich nachts auf und dann
steht sie da und ich das will ich
einfach auch jetzt noch nicht später
vielleicht ich würde mich freuen wenn es
gleich los wird weil ich finde dass sie
einen extrem
differenzierte darstellung wieder
hinlegt
meine frau schreibt gott sei dank nicht
andernfalls hätte ich wohl eine
anhaltende schreibblockade hollywood
liebt solche rollen und schlecht spielt
sie das weiß gott mich sie es überhaupt
das einzig gute an diesem sehr sehr
langweiligen film über die frau des
nobelpreisträgers gewinnen in meinen
augen sollte ganz klar ja die tradition
roma das ist eine fantastische rolle das
ist eine so großartige darbietung die
diese junge mir völlig unbekannte
schauspielerin geliefert die beste
hauptdarstellerin ist natürlich lady
gaga weil die beste hauptdarstellerin
das glaube ich vermute sogar dass wir
die gaga das bin ich das
das bist du dir das gerade eingefallen
ist ziemlich gut